Terry how do you know when you're
hitting your mark with a character or a
scene I don't I don't I mean I think I
think I can feel if I'm being honest
with the character and trying to portray
what I want to try but you can think
you're doing an incredible job and be
completely off your mark I don't know I
i am one of the people that i usually
can't even watch my work and it's scary
it's it's for me I I'll do the best I
can and I guess the advice I gave my son
is the advice i'll give to myself just
I'll do the best that I can and I can
hope and pray that I hit the mark but I
don't I can never say if I actually know
if I did especially in film whenever
there's so many takes and so many
everything's I can only hope and um be
trying honest with myself with the work
that I'm doing and hope it's right what
is that about not being able to watch
yourself or even some people hear
themselves in reporting Lee hate no but
that's just so straight I know and I
hear that from so many ppl vres i don't
know i think it's i think it's true for
a lot of people because if you watch
yourself you watch anything you didn't
hear like oh I should have done this or
like even when you're done it you'll
your character will evolve way after you
haven't filmed it and you're like mmm i
wish that i had this or like you hear
somebody say something you're like oh i
wish i knew that before I like just no
matter what I feel like for me I've
never i never have seen something I've
done and been like yep that's it that's
perfect i'm great i am always like oh i
wish i didn't do this i wish i didn't do
that or I wish I I got myself to this
point
um you're your toughest critic I don't
know I don't know whenever I've hit my
mark it's it's scary so you try not to
watch yourself um that's why I take
classes is because I'll I'll force
myself to watch myself I'll force myself
to and I will always listen to every
opinion and get every direction that I
can and but whenever it's the finished
product and I know I can't change it or
fix it or help with it yeah it's print
worthy because of you always wish that
you did something different maybe not
maybe that's just where I am in my
career offense I know that I have a lot
of growing to do I've heard that from
other people as well and I've always
been shocked from from my point of view
seeing them wondering why that would be
but yet I'm hearing that as a common
yeah thank for a lot of people yes but
you will force yourself at some point
yeah and I mean I'll watch I'll watch it
is not I hope ever I hope the audience
is happier than I with it they'll say
you know every single detail that you
put into it and you know like you yeah
you know what you hope to portray and
obviously if you don't give a hundred
and ten percent of what you were
imagining that it's gonna be a
disappointment in yourself or for
yourself which is horrible it's a
horrible thing to say is your I don't
know I think no matter what your in your
your toughest critic usually
you